Das Ausmass habe ich unterschätzt.
Ich wusste vom victim blaming
und wusste in etwa,
was auf mich zukommen könnte.
Aber das Ausmass überraschte mich.
Der Film zum Thema Vergewaltigungen
löste sehr viele Reaktionen aus:
positive,
aber auch negative Reaktionen.
Die Frauen, die im Film offen
über die erlebte
sexualisierte Gewalt redeten,
wurden in den Kommentaren teils aufs
Übelste beschimpft und verunglimpft.
So heftig,
dass unser Online-Team leider
gewisse Kommentare löschen musste,
was nicht häufig der Fall ist.
Nicht über die schlimmsten Beispiele,
aber ähnliche,
reden wir hier
zusammen mit Morena Diaz,
eine der vier Protagonistinnen
des Films,
und Agota Lavoyer von der Opferhilfe-
und Beratungsstelle Lantana.
Ich lese Ihnen nun gern diese
Kommentare - es sind zwei - vor.
Z.B. konnte man lesen:
"Man soll sein Fleisch
nicht ins Schaufenster hängen,
wenn's nicht
zum Konsum geeignet ist."
"Und tust du es doch,
dann sei dir der Gefahr
durch ein paar schlecht
erzogene Triebtäter/-innen bewusst.
Ein weiterer Kommentar,
ein ähnlicher:
"Aber nicht immer
sind nur die Männer schuld."
"Die Frauen sollten auch darauf
achten, keine nackte Haut zu zeigen.
(Hotpants, Mini-Rock,
tiefer Ausschnitt). Das provoziert.
"Zieht euch einfach anständig an,
dann werden weniger Frauen
vergewaltigt."
Sie haben solche
und ähnliche Kommentare gehört.
Was macht das mit Ihnen?
Ich bin halt schon länger
in der Öffentlichkeit
und kann dementsprechend
einigermassen gut
mit Kommentaren umgehen.
Mich macht es einfach wütend,
weil ich denke:
"Wo leben wir eigentlich?
Wir sind im Jahr 2020."
Es sollte mittlerweile
jeder begriffen haben,
dass Haut zeigen
gar nichts zu bedeuten hat
und niemandem das Recht gibt, über
den Körper einer Person zu verfügen.
Weder physisch noch mental.
Es gibt sicher Kommentare,
die weh tun.
Wenn sie sehr persönlich werden,
wenn sie sagen,
ich sei eine schlechte Lehrerin,
ein schlechtes Vorbild.
Nicht die einzelnen Kommentare, aber
die Summe der vielen löst etwas aus.
Das schon.
Aber Kommentare, die v.a. Männer
schreiben, im Stil von:
"Selber schuld, schau deine Bilder
an, du zeigst Haut, provozierst":
Das macht mich wirklich wütend.
Das berührt mich nicht in der Seele,
es macht mich einfach wütend.
Ich finde:
Nein, so darf es nicht sein.
Das zeigt doch irgendwie,
Frau Lavoyer,
dass man den betroffenen Frauen
immer noch eine Mitschuld gibt,
sie mitverantwortlich macht.
Warum? Warum
machen das gewisse Leute?
Man darf wirklich nicht vergessen,
dass auch im Jahr 2020
in der Schweiz Vergewaltigungsmythen
tief verankert sind.
Das sind falsche Annahmen und
klischeehafte Überzeugungen darüber,
was eine Sexualstraftat ist,
wie ein Täter, wie ein Opfer ist.
Dazu kommt, dass man impliziert, die
Frau sei eigentlich selbst schuld
an dem, was passiert ist.
Warum man das macht?
Man weiss, Frauen machen das auch.
Da geht man davon aus,
dass es aus einem
Sicherheitsbedürfnis heraus ist.
Sie möchten die Illusion
einer heilen Welt aufrecht erhalten.
Bei den Männern ist es so, dass sie
die Schuld von sich weisen wollen.
Sexualisierte Gewalt hat sehr viel
mit Machtverhältnissen zu tun,
mit Kontrolle, Dominanz,
fehlendem Respekt gegenüber Frauen.
Da dürfen wir nicht verkennen,
dass wir immer noch in einer
patriarchalen Gesellschaft leben
und Männer sexualisierte Gewalt
gern als Frauenproblem darstellen.
Das ist es aber nicht.
Es ist nicht die Aufgabe
von uns Frauen,
uns vor sexueller Gewalt
zu schützen.
Sie selber, wenn Sie solche
Kommentare lesen:
Sie sagen, es macht Sie wütend.
Schreiben Sie auch zurück?
Verteidigen Sie sich, haben Sie
das Gefühl, Sie müssen das ...
Was auf meinen Kanälen passiert:
meistens schon.
Ich lese natürlich auch die
Kommentare auf den Onlineportalen
und in dem Medien, obwohl mir
alle sagen, ich soll das nicht.
Warum machen Sie es dann?
Ich möchte wissen,
wie die Leute denken.
Es war für mich ja nichts
überraschend. Gar nichts.
Ich dachte: "Es ist ja eigentlich
klar, ich weiss das ja."
Aber es war eine Bestätigung,
wie die Leute denken.
Natürlich nicht alle, aber ich weiss
dann, wo die Problematik ist,
und da ich mich sehr für diese Dinge
einsetze, wo ich ansetzen kann,
worüber ich reden
und was ich angehen sollte.
Man hat den Eindruck,
Sie gehen sehr professionell,
wenn man das sagen darf, und
abgeklärt mit solchen Kommentaren um.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass
man sich schon warm anziehen muss.
Ja. Und es ist auch
abhängig von der Tagesform.
Wenn es mir selber
gerade nicht so gut geht,
weiss ich auch,
dass ich mich von social media
allgemein kurz fernhalten sollte.
Denn dann treffen mich
die Kommentare schon mehr.
Was wichtig ist
bei diesen Kommentaren:
Es gibt jene,
die eindeutig sehr schlimm sind.
Die ekligen.
Die ganz schlimmen,
die man löschen muss.
Dann gibt es aber sehr viele
Kommentare, die so lieb daherkommen:
"Bist du sicher, dass er gemerkt
hat, dass du nicht willst?"
"Warum bist du
nicht einfach gegangen?"
"Die Tür war ja
nicht abgeschlossen."
Diese Kommentare sind sehr subtil
und genau so ...
Ich möchte sie nicht
mit den anderen vergleichen,
aber sie kommen meist
aus dem nahen Umfeld
und nicht von irgendwelchen Usern,
die überall herumpöbeln.
Es ist kein Internetphänomen
oder eines ganz weniger,
die in der Anonymität
irgendwelchen Blödsinn rauslassen.
Es sind Kommentare,
die die Betroffenen
täglich im nahen Umfeld hören.
Und die Leute realisieren selber
oft nicht, was sie damit sagen.
Ich nehme an, Sie haben sich
damit auseinandergesetzt,
ob sie das öffentlich machen wollen
oder nicht.
Haben Sie diese Lawine kommen sehen?
Nein, das Ausmass
habe ich unterschätzt.
Ich wusste vom victim blaming
und wusste in etwa,
was auf mich zukommen könnte.
Aber das Ausmass überraschte mich.
Ich möchte noch
auf ein paar Kommentare eingehen.
Ich habe auch den Eindruck,
dass viele ein Problem damit haben,
dass sich die Frauen jetzt stark
zeigen und öffentlich darüber reden.
Auch dazu gab es Kommentare:
"Jetzt kommen die Schreckschrauben
aus dem Nichts,
die einfach gern mal ein bisschen
im Rampenlicht stehen möchten
und ein riesiges Geltungsbedürfnis
haben."
Ein weiterer Kommentar:
"Diese mediale Zurschaustellung
halte ich kaum für den richtigen Weg,
und mit der Reaktion muss man
dann halt auch umgehen können."
Warum haben
so viele Leute Mühe damit,
dass man das offenlegt
und darüber spricht?
Es ist halt ein schwieriges Thema.
Es ist heavy.
Die Menschen möchten nicht
damit konfrontiert werden.
Sie möchten
in ihrer heilen Welt leben.
Aber auch da werden wir ja täglich
mit vielen Problemen konfrontiert.
Das ist einfach noch
etwas Riesiges dazu, denke ich.
Die Leute wollen sich nicht
damit auseinandersetzen.
Oft kommt der Vorwurf, Sie wollen
als Influencerin Aufmerksamkeit.
Dann sage ich:
"Ja, ich will Aufmerksamkeit!"
Es ist ein wichtiges Thema,
das Aufmerksamkeit verlangt.
Da sage ich nicht Nein. Ich will sie
nicht für mich, aber fürs Thema.
Jemand, der sich das
annähernd vorstellen kann,
und das müsste man heute ja können,
wenn man sich mit dem victim blaming
auseinandersetzt oder das verfolgt,
weiss:
Das würde sich niemand
freiwillig antun.
Es ist so absurd, zu denken,
das mache jemand für Aufmerksamkeit.
Was ist es für eine?
Wenn jemand
eine Vergewaltigung offenlegt,
hat eine Person viel zu verlieren
und eine kaum etwas.
Die, die viel zu verlieren hat.,
ist die Betroffene.
Sie haben auch mal gesagt,
Sie hätten sich erhofft,
dass sich noch mehr betroffene Frauen
angesprochen fühlen,
weil Sie sagen: Me too.
Ich auch, mir ist es auch passiert.
Das ist mir immer noch ein Anliegen.
Ich habe ihr das auch erzählt.
Ich bekomme täglich
so viele Nachrichten
mit schrecklichen Geschichten.
Ich lese mir alles durch und
verweise oft auf die Opferhilfe.
Ich versuche, wie eine
virtuelle Freundin da zu sein.
Aber ich denke oft:
"Ich weiss es ja. Ich weiss,
dass es ein riesiges Problem ist."
"Wie schaffe ich es, aus diesen
Nachrichten etwas zu machen?"
"Den Leuten draussen zu zeigen,
dass es ein riesiges Problem ist?"
Denn ich weiss es.
Da muss man auch daran denken,
dass es für viele
schlicht nicht möglich ist,
solche Taten offenzulegen, weil sie
das gar nicht verkraften könnten.
Du hattest diese Kraft, konntest
das. Sehr viele können das nicht.
Am Ende ist das Wichtigste,
dass es den Betroffenen wieder
gut oder immer besser geht.
Und wenn ja, wenn man
an die Öffentlichkeit geht,
würden Sie den Frauen raten,
das betreut zu machen?
Grundsätzlich schon.
Es muss jede Frau
für sich entscheiden können,
aber es ist sicher so, dass das,
was auf einen zukommt -
wir haben es von Morena Diaz
gehört - sehr heftig sein kann.
Es ist nicht einfach,
damit umzugehen.
Da ist Unterstützung sicher gut.
Ob das von einer Fachstelle
oder vom privaten Umfeld ist.
Uns ist v.a. wichtig, zu wissen,
dass eine Frau unterstützt wird.
Professionelle Unterstützung
ist natürlich umso besser.
Das war bei mir ja schon auch so.
Ich wusste, meine Mutter
und meine Familie sind da für mich.
Das wusste ich ja.
Sagten Sie Ihrer Mutter davor,
dass sie es offenlegen?
Ja. Ich wollte es im August
schon öffentlich machen,
aber das wäre zu früh gewesen, weil
ich es da erst richtig realisierte.
Da wären Sie
noch zu verletzt gewesen.
Ja, auch meine beste Freundin sagte,
ich sei noch viel zu verletzt.
Ich soll es nicht machen.
Seit dem August
hatte ich immer wieder Momente,
wo ich dachte: "Jetzt mache ich es,
jetzt mache ich es."
Irgendetwas hielt mich aber auf.
Meine Mutter wollte es einfach
wissen, sie wollte vorbereitet sein.
Es war für meine Eltern
auch nicht einfach,
weil ich medial präsent bin.
Sie werden auch
ständig damit konfrontiert.
Ich sagte ihnen im Vorfeld, was sie
sagen sollen und was nicht müssen.
Darum wollten sie vorbereitet sein
und wissen, wann ich es sage.
Es war dann ein Spontanentscheid,
das an diesem Tag offenzulegen.
Ich sagte ihnen beiden dann:
"Mami, Papi, ich mache es jetzt."
Sie rieten Ihnen also nicht davon ab?
Nie.
Zu keinem Zeitpunkt.
Sie sagten einfach: "Wenn du es
machst, sind wir für dich da."
Würden Sie es wieder tun?
- Ja.
Ich bereue gar nichts.
Weder den Zeitpunkt noch ...
Gar nichts.
Es gab nämlich auch sehr,
sehr viele positive Kommentare.
Immer wieder kam das Wort Mut vor.
Z.B. hier:
"Solche Kommentare zeigen eben auch,
wie sehr unsere Gesellschaft
ein Problem damit hat, wenn Frauen
an Selbstbewusstsein und Mut gewinnen
und solche Dinge offen aussprechen."
Oder: "Nur Mut, sprecht es aus!
Davor haben die Täter Angst."
"Ihr seid so mutig. Danke dafür."
Hat es Mut gebraucht?
Ja, total.
Ich bin ja doch auch sensibel.
Ich bin kein harter Stein.
Mit der Aussicht,
was alles auf mich zukommen könnte,
brauchte es extrem Mut, ja.
Danke allen, die sich in den
Kommentaren so konstruktiv äusserten.
Wir hoffen, es bleibt weiterhin so.
Wenn ihr nichts verpassen möchtet,
abonniert doch unseren Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke!